but we're not trying to poison anybody
we're just trying to tell you hey man
here's what's going on and if you
understand this line of thinking your
life will be better for it and I have
um I have something out that I'm going
to release soon it's in the works it's
like actually I'm very solution oriented
okay all right and so we have all these
women that weren't like raised to be
wives right and I can even say like I
never try to act like I'm better than
anyone or anything and I was like we
should have like a wife School
so I'll bring in I'm gonna I'm gonna get
and it's kind of in the works there's
gonna be like sessions and it's gonna be
like and it's gonna be like
um basically we're gonna bring in actual
wives because they'll always say in the
comments well you're not a wife and I'm
like I'm not leading the training
step one hide a hoe yes oh yes yes she
she hashtag hi to ho that's hoe into
housewife University yeah yeah basically
that is Triple H U unbelievable so what
I want to do is they'll be like um you
know like a fashion class and like like
I had a dress like a wife we'll be like
put the hoop earrings down put the hoop
earrings down put the pearl necklace on
yeah and then and then it's gonna be
like
um etiquette school I'm like I'm gonna
have different
um you know and then another one I want
to do is approaching men because it's
kind of like like a lot of girls and I
I'd say myself included like when's the
last time you actually went up to a guy
that like what what percent of guys do
you find attractive and it's like so
it's like it's like so you should
probably go after the ones you want
right and if you if the ones you want
keep not wanting you then you then you
know drop it down of course but it's
like you know how can you complain if
you don't get the outcome you want if
you don't go for it like you know like
you might you might take it now but sure
I'd rather go down saying I went for
what I wanted and you are the exception
to the rule and that is not like you're
different in that regard because dude
most women can't stomach rejection most
women can't stand being rejected even
when the guy approached them much less
going up to a guy and trying to hit on
him that's not what women are designed
to do and and the thing is like a lot of
times I think as women we get resentful
like we do a lot for a guy we resent him
but it's kind of like
um okay I I feel like it's like you know
do your best and like if you if you take
the L you take the L it happens move on
yeah you know but yeah but we can't we
can't like do a lot for a guy and then
throw it in his face later that doesn't
really make sense it's called score
keeping man yeah it's like it's like if
you do that if you do a lot do it
because you actually want him to do well
with or without you right you know right
yeah that makes sense and the thing is
this is especially in I'm sure on your
podcast and as well as fresh and fit the
anytime you ask women would you do x y z
for a man 11 times out of ten the answer
is always no and the reason why it's no
bless you the reason why it's no Devin's
still under the weather guys bless her
heart but the reason why the answer is
no is because they're thinking of this
imaginary disembodied guy they're not
really thinking about a guy who has
everything they want well and I think
they allow a lot of times they'll think
of the guy they did everything for and
got nothing out there you go but it's
like how many times do guys take us on
dates and get nothing out of it and do
they do so much for us so like yeah like
put yourself but a lot of times like we
can't even be emote like like we're not
even emotional enough to like to like be
able to put put your like feelings out
there and you take the L you take the L
learn from it and move on oh my God like
like even my dad like like he's so funny
because his like dating advice is so
simple like I remember there was a guy
um that I was like Dad like I really
like him but he said like he's just not
like he doesn't like me or whatever and
he's like okay yeah so find someone who
does
well okay well all right Dad all right
God damn it but I don't want the guy who
likes me I want the guy who doesn't like
me Dad I'm a woman I'm a woman that's
how it goes does your is your dad aware
of what you do to the degree that you do
it or or is he just kind of like ah you
know my daughter does a podcast no
no could I do I mean he agrees with some
stuff indeed you don't you know funny
you know what he disagrees
agrees ain't older men he my dad's so
logical he's like they should date
younger men because women live longer
yeah
I guess oh my God practical perspective
what hey your dad's your your dad is a
smart guy man yeah uh shout out to uh Mr
Pearl
um Jay Blaze with the five dollar with
the five dollar Super Chat says liberals
should watch Pearl's conservative Jess
most people are shown liberal ideas are
correct love the idea of finishing
school for women Pearl I actually had a
conversation with Tallulah
um on on my podcast about finishing
school and how beneficial it would be to
women do you think that modern women
would even consider going to finishing
school or to me that would be completely
out of the question there's no way they
would ever even go for that I think most
won't but I think some will
I think there's some girls out there
that are generally like confused about
men okay and I I would say like
um you know like even even me like
there's some things I didn't understand
about men until I started watching red
pill content right right and you know uh
what kind of things didn't you
understand about men
um because this is a very the red pill
Community as you probably figured out
we're it's very unforgiving
um they don't like it when women come
into the space they really don't so
what's that so so so what have you
learned about men from the outside
looking in rather from the inside if
that makes sense I'll give you an
example I I feel like in and I've been
in a relationship where like I I was
hurt by someone okay and so I kind of
looked for problems with the next person
oh okay and I just realized like I was
like a headache to him because like I
was looking for problems and like and I
would say like you know if a guy is
gonna gonna cheat or gonna do something
like that like you kind of just has to
let him do what he's gonna do okay and I
I don't condone cheating um I don't I
don't like it sure but it's like what
what it what good is it gonna do for you
to like look like it's kind of like it's
not feminine to like look for problems
it's kind of like if it comes to you
that's one thing sure I think that's
like I don't want to say like let him
cheat but and I feel like men are more
likely to be faithful to you if you just
like if you leave us yeah yeah alone and
men men don't want to talk to us either
that's the other thing I learned that is
that is listen that was going to be my
next question the transition I'm gonna
read the super chat then we'll get into
that uh age of machines 5 Super Chat he
said that disembodied comment is real uh
with women mom included I have to check
them and ask them uh ask them what did I
say or how does that apply to me yeah
again hey would you would you ever cook
for a man hell no oh would you cook for
Denzel Washington well yes of course she
would yeah that just proves that that
you're not thinking and listen to be
fair to the women
when you ask would you do XYZ for a man
you're not you're there's no
qualifications you're just telling a man
just average Rank and file man
approaching talking when you say that
men don't want to talk to you anymore
what does that mean oh like men
it's like when they get home they just
want to relax oh yes like we want to
tell you about our day
and and I remember like I've been in a
relationship where like I came I came
back like and he was like could you just
could you just please just and and I
don't even be like that was so rude but
like it's kind of like us women a lot of
times we take things personal sure and I
think we're partially narcissist as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible